foreign
[Music]
so yeah we are going to compare the
various designs and sizes of dragon
heads seen in Game of Thrones and House
of the Dragon TV shows which are in the
same universe so let's get into it
firstly air ax this young juvenile
dragon is white in color with red
markings in his Frills as well as black
and darker shades on his osteaderms and
Tiny horn outgrowths his head possesses
a blunt and short a snout kind of
dinosaur in like his skull would have
been a little bit over two feet long or
60 centimeters
second vormax the green dragon of
jacaris valerion has grown quite a bit
between the time jumps he now has a 1.2
meters or 4 feet long head he still has
two very large golden eyes and a short
snout like air acts but he has more
horns around the back of the skull that
are bronze and brown in color and
stunted in growth
number three Sunfire his head is golden
in color with two iconic long horns and
a set of Shadow ones in the cheeks and
behind the head his head size would be
bigger than Vermax by the end of the
first season maybe more than five to six
feet long or 1.5 to 1.8 meters including
the massive horns
number four Cyrax this Noble she dragon
has a horse-like face which implies
along the snout but one that ends in a
mouth with a visible lip she also has
four prominent horns that are blunt and
shaped but have the same color as the
scales which are yellow golden in color
Cyrus's head is close to six feet long
including the horns
number five sea smoke this Dragon of
Leno Valerian was only seen in the early
episodes of the show and although he
wasn't that big he was still formidable
sea smoke has an ashy white colored
scaly skin with two long curvy horns in
the back of the eyes he was also of the
same size as Cyrax
number six galaxies the blood worm of
Prince Daemon was a deformed dragon and
hence had a unique facial design his
snout starts out wide but ends in a very
narrow arrow-like form the eyes have two
prominent horns growing on top of them
he was also red in color and the head
size would be around 7 to 8 feet or 2.1
to 2.4 meters long
number 7 rhaegar the first here from
Game of Thrones rhaegar has a very
crocodilian dinosaur in like face with
two long horns a pair of middle-sized
ones and holes of ostriderms all around
his face and the back of his head
Regal's head would be around six feet
long but 10 feet or 3 meters if included
with the horns number eight viserion
originally creamish yellow in color with
dark green and black outlines viserion
was turned by the ninth King into a
bluish black dragon like the other
dragons of Daenerys he has a very
angular dinosaurian snout with two pairs
of long horns middle ones and a bunch of
smaller ones
number nine drogon the black dragon of
Daenerys Targaryen was the biggest among
the three and shared the same dimensions
and facial designs as rhaegar and
viserion aside from the black scales and
reddish highlights the only difference
is size with a 7 feet head and 14 feet
long or 4.2 meters including the horns
number 10 melees the Red Queen has a
redhead with a crown of horns the line
the back of her skull in a full circle
protecting her neck melees also has a
narrower snout which is more angular in
shape the head comes to around 3 meters
or 10 feet long but the biggest horn
gives it an addition of six feet a 1.8
meters extra
number 11 dream fire this she Dragon was
seen slightly in the episode of Eamonn
and the pink Fury dream fire has a head
and a face that is very similar to
Danny's dragons but the color is bright
blue unlike the dead viserion she also
has a bigger head around 16.5 feet long
or 5 meters with the horns
number 12 vermouth Hall this was the
third largest dragon and clearly had a
massive head at close to 12 feet long or
3.6 meters and with the horns it equals
to 18 feet of 5.6 meters long Verma Thor
has horns and osteaderms that resemble
branches or roots of a dead and dying
tree and with his bronze color makes him
resemble it more
number 13 vegar this is the biggest of
the living dragons in House of the
Dragon she has a very dinosaurian-like
face with a long snout and a white mouth
but very short horns that could just be
long osteaderms as well which are pale
in color her head would be around 18
feet long or close to 5.6 meters with a
mouth that can stretch to 10 to 12 feet
wide and 14 balerion the black dread has
the biggest skull of any dragon in Game
of Thrones or House of the Dragon but we
only get to see the skull of the Dead
base he's said to be totally black in
color and his mouth was so wide that it
could swallow mammoth's whole his head
including the horns as seen beneath the
throne room would be around 26 feet or 8
meters long and close to 10 feet or 3
meters in height
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos here on this channel till
the next one take care fam